le coup d'envoi du baccalauréat c'est le
11 juin prochain pour 640 mille élèves
de terminale pour ceux qui m'achètent
d'arrache-pied un moment de détente
entre deux annales du bac avec un autre
style ouvrage les perles qui ressemble
qui rassemble les bourdes pour ne pas
dire plus des lycéens comment sont-elles
compiler et qu'en pensent les futurs
bacheliers et réponses avec jenny briffa
et josé boulesteix terminus pour les
terminales dans quelques jours le lycée
c'est fini à condition de décrocher son
bac mais voilà quand on tombe sur ce
genre de sujet le passé at il plus de
réalité clés à venir quand on sait pas
on raconte souvent n'importe quoi dans
cet ouvrage un petit florilège des
perles du bac 2006 picasso a représenté
les demoiselles d'avignon sous forme de
cube c'est sa période cubaine les
populations étaient 10 mai par la lettre
le peste le cholestérol
réponse du tac au tac
une tactique qui a ses limites
remarque très vite donc on n'a pas le
temps parfois de se relire donc fait
pardon j'ai vu violoncelle c'est l'écrit
est elle
celui qui met son grain de sel dans les
corrections du bac c'est lui depuis dix
ans philippe mignaval récolte les
âneries de les collégiens et des
bacheliers donc voilà plusieurs années
de travail à la recherche de perles du
baccalauréat
ces sources les professeurs eux-mêmes
par lettre ou par e-mail il vit refiler
leurs meilleures perles et le cru 2007
et prometteur
ryan élèves qui lors du bac blanc donc
en février ou mars dernier
écrit dans sa copie le contrat social
qui énerve de rousseau le contrat social
c'est un contrat que rousseau a signé
avec une assistante sociale parce qu'il
avait trop d'enfants mais les élèves ne
sont pas les seuls spécialistes des
bourdes
quand leurs professeurs passer le bac ce
n'était pas plus glorieux c'est un
souvenir personnel de bach un copain qui
sort de l'épreuve d'histoire géographie
et en fait il y avait un fond de carte
où il fallait placer les pays d'amérique
latine et et vient vraiment en étant un
killer en disant l'afrique pas de
problème j'ai tout placé pour ne pas
dépasser leurs maîtres les élèves ont
encore le temps de donner un dernier
coup de collier afin de ne pas enfiler
les perles le jour du bac